good evening and welcome to a special
edition of Tucker Carlson tonight happy
Good Friday this is the saddest at the
same time by far the most hopeful day on
the Christian calendar there was a time
not so long ago when the overwhelming
majority of Americans observed Good
Friday they got up they went to church
they talked about it at the office and
at dinner that night it was part of
their culture that's no longer true
tonight you wonder how many Americans
even know it's good Friday so after
hundreds of years this has finally
become a non-Christian country but it's
not a secular country you sometimes hear
people call it that but they are wrong
there are no secular countries
every country has a religion because
every person has a religion even if it's
atheism everybody worships something
we're born that way we can't get away
from it so what is America's religion
now well as it happens we have video
this is from Saint Mark's Lutheran
Church in Fargo North Dakota it was
taken on April 2nd that was the first
Sunday after the mass killing in
Nashville in which three adults and
three children were murdered at a
Christian School for being Christians
in the old America Christian pastors
would have preached about this they
would have acknowledged the evil on
display and they would have prayed for
those who'd been killed
a form of that is still happening today
but the roles have been inverted in
America's new religion the victims are
not the children who died in Nashville
the victim is the woman who killed them
because Audrey Hale called herself
transgender she was by definition a holy
martyr
watch this pastor in a formerly
Christian Church compare Audrey Hale to
Jesus
leaders were looking for any excuse
valid or not
to crucify Jesus
and they found that reason
it's baffling to me that someone's
existence
can be so threatening
that people decide they need to be
controlled that they need to have laws
made against them
or even worse
that the people that they find to be so
threatening
should die
so Audrey Hale's very existence as a
transgender person was so threatening to
authorities that they killed her just as
the Pharisees killed Jesus her death had
nothing to do with the fact she just
murdered six people
that was the pastor's Sherman at St
Mark's in Fargo
so it's pretty clear that Saint Mark's
Lutheran Church is no longer a Christian
church so what is it now well it's a
transgenderous church one of many
transgenderism is this country's
Priestess growing religion like many
faiths its theology features a
supernatural Transfiguration the moment
a person is transmogrified from one sex
to another
converts to this Faith abandoned their
old lives and embrace an entirely new
former identities no longer exist
they're dead names
but here's one big difference
transgenderists do not believe in the
god of monotheism they believe that they
themselves are God with the power to
control nature
and if you think about it this should be
a concern because it's a recipe for
extremism
people who believe that their God tend
to react very badly when told that
they're not
so if you're running the government and
you wanted to prevent violence in your
own country you would be very concerned
about the growth of a cult like this
but the by-demonistration is not
concerned at all in fact it is cheering
this cult on
watch Joe Biden's spokeswoman just days
after the massacre of children in
Nashville explained that when
transgenderists quote fight back she
approves
14 states have now banned gender
affirming Health Care while some of
these laws are currently blocked by
courts this is a dangerous a dangerous
attack this is awful news we'll be very
clear about that
lgbtq I plus kids are resilient they are
Fierce they fight back they're not going
anywhere
and we have their back this
Administration has their back
they are Fierce they fight back this
Administration has had back so this is
coming on the heels just days after a
massacre in which children were murdered
apparently in response to laws against
and surgical castration of children
so the White House is not decrying that
the White House is endorsing it as
clearly as it possibly could and that's
why no one from the Biden White House is
visiting The Grieving Christian families
in Nashville
instead today Kamala Harris went to
Nashville
to promote three Democratic party
legislators who led a ride at the State
House a riot designed to promote yes the
cult of transgenderism
so consider the message here we're on
your side and not only we're on your
side you the mentally ill who may be
armed are the victims and you were being
genocided your very existence is at
stake in other words making paranoid
people on the edge more paranoid
so fight back you are fierce
this is not the message to give to
religious nuts with weapons and
particularly not this group of religious
nuts with weapons this is a group that
has for years been committing acts of
violence at rates much higher than you
would expect across a cross-section of
the population
do you have a few examples last year a
trans girl tried to assassinate against
Augustus Brett Kavanaugh at his home
then he self-described non-binary
shooter also a member of the cult
murdered five people at a Colorado
nightclub
in 2019 a trans teenager shot nine
people in a high school killing one that
was in Denver
in 2018 a mentally ill transgenderist
shot up a Rite Aid distribution center
in Aberdeen Maryland that Massacre
killed four
so you can see where this is going and
you shouldn't be surprised by it
mental illness leads to violence this is
a species of mental illness and there's
no mental illness greater than the
delusion that you are God and that's
exactly what this cult teaches its
adherence your God you can change nature
with your will
biology
now with the endorsement of the bite
Administration the terrorism that is the
inevitable result of this belief system
is accelerating police just arrested a
man call William Whitworth he's a
transgenderist uses the name Lily in the
state of Colorado apparently had a kill
list and a Manifesto he was planning to
attack three schools and churches and
apparently some talk show hosts too
so it would be nice to see this
Manifesto or the kill list but of course
you can't see it because the authorities
are as they have in Nashville hiding it
now why are they hiding it
because they have to when your religious
views violate the unyielding laws of
nature itself you have no choice but to
hide things you have to deception is
mandatory and it will soon be reflected
in the law that is already happening in
Canada which is in some sense the new
California if you want to know our
future look North not West
in Canada transgenderism
will soon be the justification for
suspending all freedom of speech
a new law will ban speech that offends
transgenderists near drag performances
so you can't complain
watch
the drag communities are do are are done
waiting for this government to take real
action in effective ways and so is the
Ontario NDP the proposed legislation
does two things and I will go through
them firstly it enables the Attorney
General to create a 2s LGBT Qi plus
Community safety zone to prohibit within
a hundred meters of the property any
homophobic transphobic Act of
intimidation threat offensive threats
offensive remarks protest disturbance
and distribution of hate propaganda
within the meaning of the criminal code
it also comes with it a penalty of
twenty five thousand dollars if
prosecuted successfully
so here's a rule of thumb that is worth
tacking on your refrigerator because it
explains so much if the people who claim
to be victims are working to oppress you
they're not actually victims they are
oppressors
and once again with this cult
specifically that is inevitable because
at its core is a provable lie defied and
revealed by the unchanging laws of
science we do not have the power to
change our sex it is in our DNA it is in
our bone structure you dig up a
fossilized skeleton thousands of years
later and you can tell it sex we can't
change that much as we might want to
much as we might feel deep sympathy for
those who want to we still can't change
it that is true
and so of course they have to
criminalize your observing that it's
true because that is a challenge to the
core of their faith these are religious
extremists on a Jihad against the
population
in an order to win they have to force
everyone to lie period
but there are always a few who refuse no
matter what to lie and one of those is
Riley Gaines so last year rally games
was a Collegiate swimmer at the
University of Kentucky during an NCAA
Championship she and her teammates were
forced to compete against a man called
William Thomas
now there's been a lot of news coverage
of William Thomas
but here's the truth Thomas had been a
male swimmer at the University of
Pennsylvania and he had a lackluster
swimming career so he came up with a
plan he decided to give himself a female
name and soon he started winning women's
swimming competitions so what do you
call that well you call it cheating
that's cheating and Thomas's cheating
was not a secret it was obvious to
everybody
but only Riley Gaines was brave enough
to say something about it she came on
our show last July
that night we watched Leah Thomas win a
National Title and blow all the other
females completely out of the water and
that next day we came back and the mood
had shifted to where people were mad the
girls you know there were tears these
poor 9th and 17th Place finishers who
missed out on being named an
All-American there's extreme discomfort
in the locker room there's you know kind
of these grumbles is he wandering around
the women's locker room
something you know we were forewarned
about which I don't think is right in
any means changing in a locker room with
someone who has different parts
so you can probably tell just from that
clip that Riley Gaines is not an
ideologue she's not a political activist
she was a college swimmer and assumed
that she would be just that a college
swimmer but she was forced into a place
where she had no choice but to tell the
truth she was not going to violate her
own conscience the story she told was
almost hard to believe in a supposedly
rational country but it was real
and because nobody else had the courage
to stop this trend before it accelerated
similar things began to happen all over
American Sports
and with predictable results
in November the National Hockey League
sponsored an all-trans draft tournament
a male crossdresser was led to compete
against women what do you think happened
well during the game the man lightly
checked a woman into the boards and gave
her a concussion yeah because he's a man
she's a woman
in October at North Carolina High School
volleyball players suffered a
significant head injury after another
man dressed as a woman spiked a ball at
her head you can watch that on YouTube
it's on video it's awful
but nobody should be surprised that it
happened nine years ago a man called
Fallon Fox declared himself a woman and
competed in a mixed martial arts fight
against a competitor called Tamika
Prince was a woman
in a total of 36 seconds on the mat Fox
fractured the bones in Tamika Brent's
face and won the fight
as Jamaica Brent's later put it quote
I've never felt so overpowered in my
life and I'm an abnormally strong female
well yeah because even an abnormally
strong female which she is is no match
for most biological men
everybody knows that it is measurable we
don't need to guess
but almost nobody at this point at this
deeply
contemptible point of cowardice in the
west almost nobody will say that because
they're afraid
but rally games will say that because
she's not afraid so last night Gaines
went to San Francisco State University
to talk about her experiences in NCAA
swimming and relegates is not a hater
she is a measured decent person who
believes in logic and reason and finding
common ground with people who disagree
with her
she does not think she is God
but that fact does not believe she's
makes her a terrifying threat to the
zealots who do do their God
and so at San Francisco State last night
the zealous attacked her a mob
surrounded Riley Gaines and prevented
her from moving through the hallways at
one point the thug said they wouldn't
let her pass unless sheep
during the chaos a man dressed as a
woman punched her several times the mob
howled with rage screaming threats and
obscenities
we're not overstating here's what it
looked like
[Music]
yeah
it's just me I'm good
I'm good
I'm coming I'm good I'm good trust me
[Music]
that's the most dangerous extremist
group in the United States there's no
mistaking it Riley Gaines once again is
not an ideologue or a demagogue she's
not out to hurt anybody she's a college
swimmer who was cheated against
and doesn't think that's fair
in the face of that people threaten her
life and scream transparently
nonsensical things like trans women or
women trans women are not women women
are men are women and men are men
and that's unalterable and if you think
otherwise you were delusional
and they are delusional and therefore
dangerous
last night Riley Gaines was silenced and
assaulted at San Francisco State her
most basic civil rights were stolen by a
violent mob
the thing was supposed to be on the
lookout for well there it is
if there is such a thing as a hate crime
you just saw it
and yet the bus station and it's
thoroughly corrupt Department of Justice
won't acknowledge that any of that
happened because they endorse it
happening subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight